well for decades Americans have been
getting fatter and fatter and honestly
it's probably not good past a certain
point
how did this happen is the question the
government is you know has been trying
to improve our health for an awfully
long time the issue dietary guidelines
and if you follow those guidelines you
get thin and healthy right but one
matter look carefully at those
guidelines has concluded that they made
things worse
because they were wrong I mean the tech
holes is a science journalist author of
the book the big fat surprise and she
joins us Amy and thanks for coming on
well thanks for having me so this seems
like one of those stories that everyone
would be talking it seems like a scandal
I'm a big scandal government Dietary
Guidelines had the opposite effect of
what they said they would is that true
and if so how did that happen well it's
obviously a controversial subject which
is why maybe you don't hear more about
it but you know the reality is that but
BC in America was continuing along at a
very kind of reasonable low late in rate
until 1980 and then it turned sharply
upwards what happened in 1980 in 1980s
when the US government launched the u.s.
Dietary Guidelines for all Americans and
those dietary guidelines basically told
everybody in America to eat over 50% of
their calories mainly as grains right
greens fatten cow and it turns out that
eating 7 to 11 servings of bread every
day which is what we've been told to do
is also proven to be fattening to
Americans and you know so eases policy
for nearly 40 years now right so we have
and the conventional argument for why we
are fat and diabetic as a nation now is
you know ever-increasing rates is that
we don't follow the guidelines it's our
fault it's a fault of Americans for
failing to follow the guidelines and
being too lazy and not doing enough
exercise but if one of the things that I
did was to really look very closely at
the best available government data and
what you see is that Americans I've have
actually really faithfully followed the
guidelines in every single category you
can look at you know red meat since 1970
red meat is down by 28 percent animal
fats down by 27 percent butter down by 9
percent whole milk down by 79 percent
and we have faithfully increased
everything we're supposed to increase we
eat 25% more vegetables 35% more fruit
we eat 28% more grains 87 percent more
polyunsaturated vegetable oils as we've
been told and on exercise side now more
than 54 percent of Americans meet the
government's physical activity
guidelines which is up from about 40 44
percent in 2005 so in fact Americans are
doing a really good job they're
exercising more and they're eating into
every other instructions they're
following that the instructions are
wrong amazing yeah thank you for that
well yeah I mean that's just like we're
unfortunately out of time but you
summarized it perfectly and maybe we
should rethink the next set of
instructions we get well thanks a lot
thank you for having me